[Musique]
je voudrais déjà revenir un petit peu
sur tout ce qui est mondialisation on
parlait juste avant du sénat aujourd'hui
le ceta c'est pour nous un problème pour
la simple et bonne raison en fait c'est
le respect des normes
on demande en france des qualités à
voilà aux français aux agriculteurs
français conventionnelle et en bio c'est
à dire le bio en france c'est zéro
produit chimique de synthèse et le
conventionnel à des normes bien établi
aussi à respecter
aujourd'hui on veut faire rentrer en
france des produits qui ne respectent
pas ces normes là on le voit alors sur
le bio il ya encore du travail à faire
mais on voit des produits bio qui sont
importés en france
ils ont l'étiquette bio mais ne respecte
pas aujourd'hui la france en bio on est
peut-être un des pays avec d'autres où
on est ultra carré c'est à dire 0 et
produits subissent un cahier des charges
est le plus fort mais on continue à
importer des produits qui ne respectent
pas pour moi le label bio arrivée en
france et c'est là le problème et c'est
là ce qu'on voudrait appuyé c'est que
les produits qui rentrent en france
respecte les normes françaises
[Musique]